hey what's up mkbhd here so if you're
one of those people who has ever thought
wow seems like all the phones coming out
these days look and feel the same well
this one's for you because this is one
of the most contrarian against the grain
set of features i've seen in a new phone
in a long time so this is the asus
zenfone
9 and the more you look around this
phone the more you see it's just not
like very many other phones first of all
flagship phones these days are getting
bigger and bigger than ever we know this
this phone is actually refreshingly
compact it has slightly bigger bezels
but those are around a 5.9 inch display
so maybe not many but pretty close and
that translates to so many little things
just feeling smaller in the pocket
smaller in the hand obviously
reachability of the whole display is
easier it's great and then you already
know most flagships these days are
working with glass they're usually
pretty shiny and glossy backs this one
is plastic but it is a sort of a nice
textured uh softer touch plastic bag
it's not quite the rough sandstone of
the classic oneplus phones but it is
somewhere in between it's got a little
more grip which combined with the flat
aluminum sides of this phone are quite
nice to hold plus it has all these
little design cues you know the little
notch cut out around the metal of the
power button the little bits of text on
the back of the phone not full-on rog
phone levels of text but it is something
and the notch cut out around what is
that oh yes a headphone jack yet another
piece of this phone that you just don't
see very often in many new phones out
there plus just when's the last time you
saw a red phone the only thing i don't
like about this design might just be
that the size of the camera bumps makes
the whole thing rock when it's flat on a
table but we'll get to those cameras in
a second a lot of phones have been
moving their fingerprint readers to
underneath the display which
fair they've gotten pretty good lately
maybe haven't improved that much in the
last year or two asus said you know what
we're going to take this power button
and we're going to double it as our
fingerprint reader but not only that
we're going to have it triple as a smart
key so you can customize both a double
press and a long press to start a quick
action you can start google assistant
with it or open literally whatever app
you want and then not only that we're
also going to have it quadruple has a
reachability hack where you can swipe
the button down to pull the notification
shade down at any time anywhere from any
screen just like samsung did back in the
day with the galaxy s10e i think it was
and asus has really gone the extra mile
just to make sure you can reach
everything on the phone with one hand
they've also got a little edge tool to
let you quickly launch apps with your
thumb from the side what else do most
normal flagship phones have these days i
think you could argue a pretty heavily
customized software experience is pretty
common
i'm happy to report though that asus is
taking the opposite approach with a
fairly lightweight just couple of
additions on top of
nearly stock android so zen ui which is
what it's called just adds a couple
things here and there and it's doing
wonders for this phone first of all for
performance i mean there's no real
bloatware here things are pretty light
this phone also has a 120 hertz display
and combined with the top of the line
snapdragon 8 plus gen 1 and 8 to 16 gigs
of ram things have been very smooth
pretty much all the time which is
awesome and for usability they just find
a couple places to tuck some extra
features into the settings around the
material u elements that are smart like
little thoughtful additions here and
there i like i like that they lifted the
display animation speeds that are
usually buried in developer settings and
just put it right into the display
settings they always on display you can
customize a little bit to look
differently and they put a bunch of
stuff in the advanced section including
mapping a double back tap to a custom
action or a custom one-handed mode for
even better reachability and actually
one of my favorites you can super easily
customize which camera modes show up at
the bottom so you aren't always
scrolling around looking for the option
you want no matter which one it is so
then battery life yo
let me talk to you about the battery
life on this phone so typically on a
smaller phone especially a small
flagship phone that's one of the weakest
parts of the phone which makes perfect
sense there's a lot going on in a small
space so there's not a lot of room for
much battery this zenfone 9 has a 4300
milliamp hour battery which is pretty
big for the small size of this phone and
when i put my sim card in it honestly i
was expecting about the status quo you
know i set the 120 hertz refresh rate
because that's what i'm into
and i got
way
way more than i was expecting this phone
actually has
seriously incredible battery life it
sips power turns out this is actually a
really good phone to put the snapdragon
8 plus gen 1 in because not only is it
more powerful at the highest end but
it's also more efficient than the
previous chip so great standby time and
a lot of quick bursty stuff has handled
no problem but i was having like heavy
days of using a lot of high brightness
screen on time navigation playing some
games just doing a bunch of stuff that
typically drains phones and it just
lasted for a long time i was having
seven plus hour screen on time days and
ending with 10 20 left really great
battery on this phone and hey while
we're at things that punch above their
weight class the cameras back here
the cameras are probably better than
what you're expecting now the main
sensor here is actually the same one
that was in the nothing phone and the
rog phone 6 both of which took like b to
b plus quality photos at best and were a
noticeable step behind the flagships in
pretty much every way so same chip in
here but two things are different one
they put this entire sensor in this huge
six axis hybrid gimbal stabilization
setup and two we know a lot of what
makes a good smartphone camera these
days is software so the zenfone 9 takes
photos that look very different from say
the rog phone which actually asus also
makes or the nothing phone basically if
you've watched my blind smartphone
camera test in the past this statement
won't shock you but the zenfone 9 has
the closest look of a pixel phone of any
non-pixel camera so a typical zenfone 9
photo is very bold and contrasty and
saturated so straight off the rip it's
pretty nice if anything it can have the
tendency to go over the top and really
over process and over hdr things that
looks kind of harsh and you can really
see that in higher dynamic range
situations
but the extra stabilization does help
not just for video but also for taking
less noisy photos in the dark at least
on the main camera it's still not
freezing moving subjects very well
because you need a fast shutter speed
and a bigger sensor to do that reliably
but out of all the phones with this
sensor i think this one looks the best
the ultra wide is also pretty consistent
with color to match the main camera so
shout out to asus for their software
processing in the zenfone cameras over
the years maybe pass some of that along
to the uh rog phone team you know maybe
have a meeting or two so i've said a lot
of positive things about this phone so
i'm just going to say one more which is
i think the price is really good it
starts at 6.99
which actually when i first started i
put my sim card in this phone like two
weeks ago didn't really know much about
it and i hadn't been told the price yet
and i would have guessed higher than
that it kind of reminds me of when uh
pixel 5 came out and it was the best
pixel at the time but it was a
snapdragon 7 series it was 90 hertz and
we we're hoping for like a full flagship
pixel
this feels like a
pixel 5 pro like two years later it's
got the highest end chip it's got a nice
screen an incredible battery life uh
not a whole lot of downside i'm gonna
say actually this phone at this price is
my favorite release this year i am very
impressed with it now it's not perfect
and we already know no phone is perfect
it's got a few key trade-offs and so i'm
going to nitpick because that's what i
have to do
but here's what's wrong with this phone
so battery life is incredible like i
said but the max charging speed 30 watts
that's decent but there is no wireless
charging that's missing lots of people
love reminding me that they don't really
care about wireless charging but hey
almost every other phone at this price
is gonna at least have the option so
that's something to note and then this
display that i was telling you about it
is definitely super responsive at 120
hertz with a 240hz touch sample rate but
it is a slight step below the flagships
visually and it maxes out at 800 nits
when not showing hdr content which can
get washed out in direct sunlight
also the corner cutout for the selfie
camera has this little ring around it
that might be a little more distracting
than some people might like
also the speakers and small phones have
never been great because physics and
these aren't really an exception they're
fine but they're semi-easily blocked
and then probably the biggest thing i've
noticed is this soft touch red color is
very cool and i really like it but i am
concerned about how this will wear you
can see the edges and the corners of
mine are already starting to fade and
turn darker and the sunset red color is
slightly less vibrant than it was when i
first got the phone and this is only two
weeks like i haven't really had the
phone for that long so while i haven't
seen a phone with quite this finish of
plastic before i can't vouch for it
aging well now just to get ahead of the
comments that i can already see you
typing yes most people just put a case
on their phone already by default so it
does actually come with this
decidedly more plastic feeling case in
the box
but yeah i don't know i just i feel like
a phone that has a soft touch plastic
back shouldn't have to
always have a case on it the way maybe a
fragile glass one might so yeah that's
something to know and then all the power
button features i was just telling you
about
super first of all this is one of the
fastest fingerprint readers in any phone
you just graze it for a second and it
unlocks super sensitive but then the
pull down notification feature i was
accidentally triggering all the time it
kind of got annoying so i ended up
turning it off because it was getting in
the way kind of like i on the s10e i
think i also disabled it so cool for a
few days then i turned it off but yeah
this power button
this is something sustainability note
this phone isn't particularly repairable
but it does come in 100
fully recyclable packaging and it does
come with 30 watt charging brick but
yeah as far as downsides
that's pretty much it i think i can
confidently say
this is the most well-rounded
compact phone in the world
if you can consider it compact i think
there's a lot of really great things
about this phone and i'm very happy to
keep using it this is probably going to
end up extremely underrated in the us
because you don't really see zen phones
in carrier stores so most people don't
end up buying these but if you're
looking around shopping for a great
compact android phone around 700 bucks
don't even think twice this is a great
one to get
yeah
easy as that
okay that's pretty much it thanks for
watching catch you guys the next one
peace
[Music]